hey we are the cast of second act
Jennifer Lopez and we are here with
BuzzFeed playing what would you rather
have to quit your dream job or fire 100
hard-working colleagues quit my dream
job I don't want to like let someone
down if they're hardworking colleagues
be like no it's cool you guys can always
hire me back that's so sweet
would you rather have your most recent
ex as your boss or 16-year old is your
force sixteen-year-old blood yeah XD
totally cuz I'm 16 year olds for sure
would you rather find out your
significant other has never told you the
truth or that your parents have never
told you the truth my mom yes parent yes
sure Karen because we don't find our
kids all the time would you rather
accidentally send an email bad talking
your boss to your boss or accidentally
send a text bad talking your significant
other to you I'd rather do my boss you
have to live with the other one right
would you rather continue with your
career or be able to restart it
continue continue yeah Starnes in the
beginning that sounds like the worst
thing ever
themself yeah I would continue I'm
continuing to yeah you too would you
rather get a $10,000 holiday bonus or
let your best friend get a $20,000
holiday bonus I give to my friend you're
just so nice but that's real you're not
the first one cuz here but also here's a
thing forget 20 so so he's gonna tack
there you go would you rather have a
successful high-profile job with no time
family or friends
now or have an unfulfilled job with
plenty of time for family and friends
that's hard that's an awful damn
question that's a losing proposition
either way it are laid out but it's also
a big rat that's a grass greener leg
would you rather never be able to tell a
lie or never be able to tell the truth
oh yeah
telling the truth is something about a
lot so you can't tell lies or you can't
tell the truth I like the second one
people she can't you know it's not her
fault would you rather work a job you
love but never be able to retire or
would you rather work a job you loathe
but be able to retire after 10 years oh
do what I love you love forever I would
rather have J Lo's but I think America
knows what mine looks like too so yeah
those are my ass preceded my face on
this is us that's what's up my butt
before you saw my face on the show yeah
I have to take care of this yeah sorry
the same engine yeah yeah I think the
girls would take mine maybe the guys
would take yours yeah being and queen of
prom - yeah prom
yeah yeah we did grounds for that
[Music]